also wir sind mit humanitärer Hilfe
natürlich jetzt seit Tagen auch im
Einsatz sowohl für Syrien als auch für
die Türkei die Bedarfe sind enorm wir
wissen dass es mit zahlreichen Nachbeben
auch immer mehr zu neuen einstürzen und
auch Verletzten und Vermissten kommt die
Zahl korrigiert sich stündlich nach oben
und ich glaube wir sehen erst jetzt
richtig das Ausmaß dieser Katastrophe
insofern steht Deutschland bereit
natürlich humanitäre Hilfe zu leisten
tut dies auch mit suchen Rettungsteams
mit Geldern an unsere lokalen Partner
mit Hilfslieferungen des THW ist auf dem
Weg und ähm insgesamt ist ja der
europäische Krisenmechanismus auch
aktiviert worden das heißt wir stehen da
natürlich bedingungslos an der Seite der
Türkei und warten derzeit natürlich auch
auf die bedarfsanmeldung der Vereinten
Nationen um auch das deutsche Engagement
dieser Frage zu erhöhen und auch Syrien
ist ja stark betroffenen im Zusammenhang
hat ja die Außenministerin Annalena
bärbock von der Türkei gefordert
sämtliche Grenzübergänge zu Syrien nach
Syrien zu öffnen und auch darauf hat der
Botschafter bei uns geantwortet dass
dies in dieser schwierigen Lage geprüft
werde das hat er gestern bei uns gesagt
gibt es denn diesbezüglich Neuigkeiten
nicht dass ich es weiß aber zarte
Signale sage ich mal von türkischer
Seite die ist auch zuzulassen es gibt
momentan eingrenzübergang der vermutlich
auch beschädigt ist Hauer der sozusagen
offen ist und Möglichkeiten bietet
humanitäre Hilfslieferungen in die
Region zu bringen wir begrüßen wenn die
Türkei sich da stark macht aber es
braucht natürlich auch die andere Seite
und hier muss man klar sagen auch dass
Assad-Regime auch Russland können jetzt
zeigen dass ihnen die Not der Menschen
wichtiger ist als politisches Kalkül die
Grenzübergänge müssen geöffnet werden
die für Hilfslieferung um dort vor Ort
auch Hilfe zu leisten das ist zwingend
notwendig und hier sind jetzt alle
gefragt und da sind wir natürlich ähm ja
sehr gespannt was dann die nächsten
Stunden passiert diese schwierige
politische Situation wirkt sich ja fatal
aus auf die
Opfer auf die Erdbeben Opfer und auch
auf die Binnenflüchtlinge die in Syrien
an der türkischen Grenze
7 Millionen sollen es sein sich
auswirken die syrische oder das syrische
Assad-Regime hat jetzt offiziell um
internationale Hilfe gebeten hat dann
auch gesagt aber nur wenn wir das hier
über Damaskus koordinieren jetzt gibt es
ja zarte Signale also die USA haben
gesagt nee wir machen das auf gar keinen
Fall mit dem Assad Regime die EU hat
jetzt sofort Hilfe zugesagt oder für
Syrien tatsächlich 3,5 Millionen und wie
läuft das dann läuft das dann über über
Damaskus tatsächlich oder wie dürfen wir
uns das vorstellen die Hilfe der
Bundesregierung und meines Wissens auch
der EU läuft natürlich über die
Vereinten Nationen die vor Ort aktiv
sind auch seit Jahren schon ja ähm dort
Hilfen in die Region bringen auch in die
von Assad kontrollierten Gebiete aber
auch nach Nordwest Syrien also es gibt
Zugänge über die Vereinten Nationen die
koordinieren dass es auch weiterhin der
Weg der Bundesregierung wir arbeiten
seit Jahren mit lokalen Partnern und
NGOs vor Ort zusammen das ist der Weg
über Berlin ist jetzt gehen muss und
noch mal also es ist nicht Zeit über
diese Katastrophe sie so vielen Menschen
das Leben gekostet hat jetzt politische
Forderungen zu stellen alle Akteure
können jetzt zeigen dass ihnen die das
Überleben der Menschen wichtiger ist als
die politischen kalkülle und das
erwarten wir natürlich von allen
Beteiligten für uns ist klar wir
arbeiten mit unseren lokalen Partnern
vor Ort zusammen und versuchen so viel
wie möglich Hilfe in die Region zu
bringen und das ist auch das Gebot der
Stunde wir sind jetzt stand heute bei
über 15.000 Toten in der Erdbebenregion
und die Statistiken die das dann so
hochrechnen lassen Schlimmstes
befürchten für März hat die EU zu einer
Geberkonferenz eingeladen was wird
Deutschland tun wie wird sich
Deutschland beteiligen also nochmal wir
werden uns natürlich stark beteiligen
tun das jetzt schon das Auswärtige Amt
koordiniert in einem Krisenstab und wir
warten auf die Bedarfe die von den
Vereinten Nationen das ist ja immer
unsere
Leitlinie auch angemeldet werden werden
uns da stark einbringen und weitere
monetäre Hilfe leisten solange dies
notwendig ist sag aber auch ganz
deutlich ehrlich es ist auch wichtig
dass wir das hier auch in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen im Deutschen
Bundestag abbilden dass wir
Möglichkeiten haben flexibel auf solche
Katastrophen auch zu reagieren da ist
das Auswärtige Amt natürlich in der
Federführung mit der humanitären Hilfe
und da brauchen wir auch Spielräume das
sei ganz klar gesagt jetzt von meiner
Seite als Beauftragte dass wir dort auch
in den nächsten Wochen die Flexibilität
haben mit einem starken deutschen
Beitrag auch vor Ort zu unterstützen da
werden sich sicherlich mit dem
Finanzminister noch darüber unterhalten
wir bedanken uns für den Besuch hier bei
uns Luisa Amtsberg war das die
Beauftragte für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Nothilfe der Bundesregierung
vielen Dank und Sie können den Menschen
in der Türkei und in Syrien helfen zum
Beispiel über das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe hier ist die iban.de
65/100
400-00-100 400 600 das Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien alles auch noch
mal nachzulesen auf
spenden.zfunkt.de und auf der ZDF Text
Seite 8 9.0